monsieur castaner à effet une circulaire
qui permettait d' exclure toutes les
communes de moins de 2000 habitants du
comptage final ça voulait dire quoi ça
veut dire que 96% des communes
n'auraient pas été comptabilisés c'est à
dire 50 % de la population française
donc c'est totalement inacceptable et en
plus ils voulaient en termes de
nuanciers permettent aux préfectures de
faire un grand nuancé centre bon bah non
il faut que la république en marche
assume et donc accepter le résultat des
urnes à venir donc il faut au contraire
encouragé l'inscription sur les listes
électorales et créer les conditions et
bien d'un débat démocratique respecté
que ce soit par exemple les temps de
parole dans les médias que ce soit aussi
les conditions même du vote le faites ce
que vous avez quand même beaucoup une
population qui ne savent pas que les
élections auront lieu bientôt en mars
les 15 et 22 mars
cette date là n'est absolument pas
l'objet d'une campagne d'information
publique de la part du gouvernement